[Music]
if you believe that Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is going to be the only one of
this decade you might be right but in
order to make such a forecast with
confidence would require us to know for
sure how China is going to behave you
already know that this country has been
threatening to invade Taiwan for some
time now and I'm sure many of you would
think that sooner or later the island
will likely become the next Ukraine but
what if we told you that there are those
who think that ultimately the Asian
Ukraine could be Vietnam and not Taiwan
and keep in mind we are not talking
about mere speculation there are plenty
of arguments to believe that this risk
exists tension Rises between China
Vietnam and the Philippines over
disputed Islands in fact China has even
sunk Vietnamese fishing boats in the
South China Sea but let's be honest this
is nothing new for Vietnam after all the
two countries were already at war in
1979 just after the end of the famous
Civil War in which the United States
intervened but wait a minute aren't they
supposed to be both Communist Regime
countries didn't International socialism
unite them
[Music]
yes both where and supposedly still are
staunch communist regimes but when it
comes to power struggles ideology takes
a back seat the fact is that it should
come as no surprise that Vietnam is
trying to strengthen itself as much as
possible to avoid another possible
Chinese Invasion and what can I say
history tells us that this is the
smartest move it can make and not
surprisingly this is something that as
we will see is of great interest to the
United States I mean think about it the
United States wants to curb Chinese
expansionism in the South China Sea an
objective shared by Vietnam a country
that could play a crucial role in that
project
with almost 100 million inhabitants an
impressive economic growth in recent
years Vietnam is gradually emerging as
another future Regional counterweight to
China One More you know alongside Japan
South Korea Singapore the Philippines
possibly India and so many other
countries in the area China's position
is not as strong as it might appear at
first glance
[Music]
however we must not forget that Vietnam
is still a Communist dictatorship and
making alliances with authoritarian
regimes can lead to a lot of problems
just look at the NATO situation with
turkey but we'll talk about that in
another video for now the question is
can the West really trust Vietnam to
what extent could it become a reliable
military partner for the United States
could tensions between Vietnam and China
end up provoking Another War today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but first let's look at a bit of really
interesting history
[Music]
foreign
Crossroads of Asian communism
when we look at history and how China
and Vietnam are organized internally we
see that at first glance they basically
appear to be parallel realities both
countries carry out socialist
revolutions both established communist
dictatorships that are still in place
and both began to reform their economies
in order to open up to the international
market Vietnam started its economic
reform in 1986 with DOI Moy that is
eight years after genjioping's economic
reforms were launched in China the fact
is that both countries began to promote
private ownership of agricultural
property and in general in the rest of
the economy they also boosted foreign
investment and intensified their trade
relations with the rest of the world
thanks to these changes they eventually
reached a juicy result as you can see
their economies began to take off
[Music]
as you can see China which began its
reforms almost a decade earlier distance
itself from Vietnam especially when it
joined the World Trade Organization at
the beginning of the 21st century
nevertheless overall the two countries
have followed a more than remarkable
trajectory in just 30 years Vietnam has
multiplied the real value of its
production by 12 times while China has
increased its own by almost 20 times and
the truth is that we are talking about
two countries with many similarities but
that at the same time are also very
different in the case of Vietnam in
addition to arriving almost a decade
late to the wave of economic reforms it
must be taken into account that when it
did to finally arrive this country had
just gone through two Wars a Civil War
in which the United States participated
pretty famously and later a war against
China which showed up in the defense of
the Cambodian regime that committed one
of the most extensive acts of genocide
in history that of Pol Pot in general we
can say that Vietnam embraced reforms
when it was poorer and even had more
problems of all Kings than China in part
that difference explains the current gap
of course today the differences go
beyond the purely economic Realm China
between Collective power and the
personalism of Xi Jinping exactly well
in recent years personalism taken to the
extreme has regained strength with Xi
Jinping in China in Vietnam things
looked different and proof of that is
news stories like this one Vietnam
President unguyun shran quits amid
Communist Party corruption Crackdown you
see in China since 1989 the General
Secretary of the Communist party has
also been the president of the country
in Vietnam on the other hand this seems
Unthinkable today
in fact the Vietnamese Communist
dictatorship rests on four pillars the
general Secretariat the Prime Minister
the president and the leader of the
National Assembly since Ho Chi minh's
death in 1969 each of these positions
has been held by different people who
function in a way as counterweights to
each other in fact the National Assembly
of Vietnam which is obviously not
Democratic at least has some real
activity it can even veto resolutions
and if necessary propose motions of
confidence against the prime minister so
far this has allowed the official
apparatus to be somewhat more oxygenated
meanwhile in China there was the
alternation of the leader and the
current political Elites but with Xi
Jinping all of that has disappeared so
what does all this mean basically no one
in Vietnam can change course rapidly as
Xi Jinping can in China and it also
generally means fewer restrictions for
the general population for example while
in China Facebook and YouTube are
completely blocked in Vietnam there is
free access albeit with some
restrictions even to videos that
criticize the Communist party but apart
from the domestic political project the
area where we find the biggest
differences between the two countries is
mainly in their policy in the South
China Sea although well they also have
one important thing in common there both
countries claim the same territories and
that means that tensions could flare up
and history could repeat itself again
don't forget that both countries were at
War as recently as 1979. the question is
how does Vietnam hope to prevent tension
from flaring up with its northern
neighbor well let's find out
[Music]
from Russia with Love
it is inevitable every time we hear
about Vietnam we immediately think of
that war in which dozens of movies have
been made in which the United States was
involved in supporting the south of the
country with tens and tens of thousands
of soldiers to give you an idea in 1968
the North American power had almost 600
000 soldiers deployed in this country in
total the United States participated in
this war for 12 very long years but I'm
sure what many of you didn't know is
that right after this war ended China
invaded Vietnam in 1979 and apparently
today things would be much different
Vietnam's exposure to China remains
enormous
[Music]
look at this map if you pay attention
geographically Vietnam is totally at the
mercy of China either by its Border in
the north which is where the Chinese
invaded in 1979 or by the coast where in
addition to being practically surrounded
they would face the largest navy by
number of ships in the whole world and
let's not forget that to the Southwest
there is Cambodia an ally of China and
then there is Laos which could change
sites at the convenience of the highest
bidder not surprisingly faced with such
a scenario the question is can Vietnam
really have a clearly independent
discourse this is basically the reason
why Vietnam has been moving closer and
closer to countries such as Japan and
India in recent years both militarily
and commercially but let's be honest the
friendship between these countries is
rather superficial if we really want to
identify one who has always been
Vietnam's best friend we have to go to
the country that has been in all the
headlines around the world this past
year exactly we're talking about Russia
[Music]
since the Ho Chi Minh era moscow's
influence in the country has already
been infinitely greater than that of
Beijing in a way this has to do with
much of the fact that the roots of
Vietnam's communist thinking come
directly from Soviet Marxism leninism it
is not surprising therefore that it's
times with the Soviet Union were so
close which explains to a large extent
why the United States took the Vietnam
War so seriously a conflict in which
North Vietnamese troops were supported
and assisted by the Soviet Union which
is exactly what happened again when
China invaded the country in 1979 in
retaliation for Vietnam attacking and
overthrowing the Bloody Khmer Rouge in
Cambodia
whether the invasion was coming from the
Americans or the Chinese the Soviet
Union the most loyal partner of
communist Vietnam helped the country by
sending a lot of weapons such as
anti-aircraft missiles like machine guns
and the infamous AK-47 assault rifle the
point is that if the relations were
already close from that era on their
friendship grew much stronger in fact
today Russia Remains the largest arms
partner of the Vietnamese Army Russia
even has preferential access to one of
the most important Vietnamese bases the
one in Cambrian Bay but pay attention
because that's not the end of it
Vietnam did not rely on the Soviet Union
in today's Russia just to get weapons
economic cooperation has also been key
during this time do you want an example
well in recent years Vietnam has tried
to extract oil in the South China Sea
with the help of a lot of multinationals
for example the Spanish company Repsol
however we are talking about extraction
from disputed territories and naturally
the oil was going to come out faster and
with fewer problems if some Russian
state-owned company got involved and
managed to intimidate China a little bit
just a little bit particularly for fear
of damaging its relations with Moscow or
rather XI jinping's determination to
maintain those relationships and of
course the first to jump on this
opportunity was rosneft although it
later sold its entire stake to a company
that I cannot pronounce another Russian
state-owned Energy company it begins
with a zed that's the best I can do so
let me ask you a question how do you
think Vietnam repays Russia's favorites
well news stories like this are a pretty
good indication Vietnam and Thailand
abstain from U.N vote to condemn
Russia's Ukraine annexation exactly
Vietnam is one of the few countries in
the world that avoids condemning the
Russian invasion of Ukraine
and it makes sense if it wasn't for the
constant support of the Soviet Union in
the past and the current Russia Today
Vietnam would probably not be what it is
today but of course if China were to
take the initiative and punish or change
the Vietnamese government or even invade
the country and turn it into a satellite
state the Russians would be of no help
today given the new capabilities of the
Chinese Army and the Manifest weaknesses
of Russia it would be very difficult if
not impossible for Moscow to be of any
help to them and make no mistake about
it this is Crystal Clear to the decision
makers in Hanoi they have one of the
world's major powers on their doorstep a
power that is increasingly expansionist
and with which they do not get along
particularly well and in any case they
do not want to be a satellite country
[Applause]
to avoid a possible clash in recent
years Hanoi has been trying to improve
its relations with Beijing this is not
just a territorial or military issue to
put it in perspective almost 40 percent
of all Vietnamese Imports come from
China including integrated circuits
telephone semiconductors in shorts
practically everything the country needs
to develop technologically thank you
this explains for example why both
countries have carried out dozens of
military cooperation exercises during
the current century and above all it
explains the foreign policy based on the
philosophy of the three no's not to
allow foreign military bases in Vietnam
not to be part of military alliances and
not to support one country and its fight
against another all of this just in
order to not anger China but what if
this strategy was a mistake nevertheless
tensions in the South China Sea with
China have been rising over the past
decade and the situation in the region
is no longer to be taken lightly watch
this space
[Applause]
[Music]
leaving the past behind
we've told you before how Vietnam
embarked on a series of pro-market
economic reforms starting in 1986 it's
something we talked about in detail in a
past video here on visualpolitik but for
those of you who haven't seen it or
simply don't remember it at the
beginning these reforms were limited to
the agricultural sector and later jumped
to the rest of the economic sectors one
of the most important was the pursuit of
the country's industrialization at all
costs in order to succeed this required
receiving and quoting investors from the
rest of the world and trust me they took
it very seriously nowadays it is not
uncommon to see brands from all over the
world producing in Vietnam we are
talking about companies like Samsung H M
Adidas Nike and Foxconn in fact
Vietnam's largest customer by far is the
United States this is not surprising
relations with the North American
superpower have improved greatly in
recent years
gone are the times of war and mistrust
in 1995 the two countries formally
restored diplomatic relations and in
2000 they signed a bilateral Trade
Agreement in 2007 Vietnam joined the
World Trade Organization with
Washington's explicit support and in
2016 the United States completely lifted
the arms embargo on Vietnam allowing for
greater cooperation on security and
defense issues we could even see images
like this one
since then the two countries have
conducted numerous joint military
exercise and routinely collaborate on
Maritime security and freedom of
navigation in the indo-pacific region
now while we have told you that Vietnam
has tried to get along as well as
possible with China what explains its
sudden desire to create a link with its
historical arch enemy and China's
current great adversary
foreign
the truth is that in Hanoi they do not
trust Beijing at all in fact in 2014
tension between the two countries
reached an extreme level when China
brought a semi-submersible oil platform
to explore and exploit oil within
Vietnamese Maritime territory and not
only that the construction of artificial
islands around the spratly and Paracel
archipelagos which Vietnam claims as its
own has caused tension to grow in the
region especially because of the
military hardware that China is
installing on these islands that is why
in Hanoi they now seem to understand
that neither Moscow nor Beijing are
their safest bets but instead they need
to look to the United States and its
orbit of Allied countries in the area of
course Washington has seen this shift as
a stroke of Good Fortune as another
potential partner to add to its already
long list of countries angry or
suspicious of China and in a way that's
what explains news stories like these
29th of March 2018 the United States
transfers six metal shark Patrol boats
to Vietnam
20th of November 2019 U.S gift ship to
Vietnam to boost Patrols in disputed
South China Sea
17th of December 2022 analysis Vietnam
shift gears on arms trade as it loosens
ties with Russia no instead of buying
Russian weapons it is American South
Korean and Israeli weapons that are
flooding into Vietnam now does this mean
that Vietnam is going to change its
three nodes philosophy and threw itself
completely into the arms of Uncle Sam
well definitely not
Vietnam is a strange case of a country
that right now seems to want to get
along with Beijing Moscow and Washington
all at the same time and make no mistake
Vietnam is still a Communist
dictatorship Western political and
Democratic forces are not part of the
communist country and this limits the
confidence that the United States places
in Vietnam not surprisingly it is
practically impossible to imagine
Vietnam intervening alongside the United
States and Taiwan to prevent an attack
by China but for now the questions are
over to you if you were Vietnam who
would you side with Moscow Beijing or
Washington leave us your answers in the
comments below and let's open a
respectable debate if you find this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so thank you very much for watching
all the best
see you next time
[Music]